في المقابل نشرت قوات الدعم السريع لقطات
فيديو تظهر انتشار عناصرها في مبنى القصر
الجمهوري وسط العاصمه الخرطوم وقالت قوات
الدعم السريع انها تسيطر تماما على القصر
الجمهوري ومحيطه في الخرطوم بالاضافه الى
مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون في ام درمان كما
اكد احد قاده الدعم السريع ان سيطرتهم على
القصر الجمهوري تاتي ضمن مساعد دعم السريع
للحفاظ على ثروات الشعب السوداني
قوات الدعم السريع من داخل القصر الجمهوري
نود ان نوص الرساله
لشعبنا الكريم ولشرفاء القوات المسلحه
اولا
نناشد كل الشرفاء في قوات الشعب المسلح
بان هذا العمل الذي زجت فيه القوات
المسلحه هو عمل يخدم افراد واشخاص محددين
في القوات المسلحه والغرض الاساسي منه
النازل دارين السولو على سلطه الشعب
السوداني وعن طريق كوميتو نحن الان في
قوات الدعم السريع بالناشد كل القوات
المسلحه وشرفاء القوات المسلحه بانه نحن
ما عاد بالنسبه لهم وانما نحن نريد ان
نحافظ على سلطه الشعب لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات